Фінансова імперія - так називали бізнес Євгена Пригожина.
Журналісти-розслідувачі деякий час тому виявили кілька сотень компаній,
пов'язаних з його ім'ям.
Але ніхто так і не дізнався, де його бізнес починається, а де закінчується.
Це, звісно, кейтеринг, це ресторани.
Складно сказати, який із цих ресторанів прибутковий, який збитковий.
Це всі структури, назвемо їх "Московський школяр",
їх там кілька десятків компаній, а може й сотень,
які постачали за держконтрактами їжу до московських шкіл та дитячих садків.
Це гігантський ринок, і він там був майже монополістом.
Але найвідоміше "підприємство" Пригожина - це ПВК "Вагнер".
Найманці воювали у війні Росії проти України,
а також були присутні в Сирії, Судані та Центральноафриканській республіці.
У цих країнах бізнес-інтереси Пригожина тісно перепліталися з політикою.
У Сирії вони намагалися освоїти нафту та газ,
у Судані добували золото, у ЦАР - золото та алмази.
Це не означає, що ця гілка була самоокупною.
Але вони намагалися хоч щось заробити на тому, що вони роблять.
Ми по витоку з бухгалтерії бачили, що це такий планово-збитковий захід,
який робиться, щоб у Пригожина були якісь політичні бали, мовляв,
ми просуваємо інтереси Росії.
Це було важливо, мабуть, для Кремля, для Путіна.
Здавалося, такі розгалужені бізнес-активи колишнього кремлівського кухаря
мають становити інтерес і після його загибелі.
Але поки що на них ніхто не претендує.
Експерти вважають причиною те, що майже весь бізнес Пригожина
будувався на особистих зв'язках.
Зрозуміло, що люди фізично нікуди не подінуться,
десь кудись їх спробують перенаправити,
віддати іншим командирам, хтось просто перейде в аналогічні підприємства,
хтось додому поїде, але все.
Так само, як Федеральне агентство новин, було - було, клац, все, немає.
Головне питання - що буде з ПВК "Вагнер",
яка після спроби заколоту в Росії передислокувалася до Білорусі.
Олександр Лукашенко повідомив, що ця група залишиться на території Білорусі.
Але водночас стало відомо про те,
що наметовий табір у Могильовській області почали демонтувати.
Тут лишається ядро.
Хтось поїхав у відпустку, хтось взагалі вирішив жити осторонь,
але телефони, адреси, паролі, явки у цьому штабі, у цьому ядрі відомі.
Протягом кількох днів усі будуть тут, до десяти тисяч людей.
Хоча, за словами Лукашенка, він не знає, хто може стояти за збиттям літака Пригожина,
він упевнений, що Володимир Путін до цього не причетний.
Слухайте, надто брутальна непрофесійна робота,
якщо вже на те пішло. Це не схоже на Путіна.
Але що б там не трапилося, хоч би як там трапилося, все одно це звалять на Путіна.
Лукашенко також висловився і про гарантії безпеки,
які він нібито давав Пригожину після невдалого заколоту "вагнерівців" в Росії.
Якщо вже прямо відповідати на це запитання, я і не маю забезпечувати безпеку Пригожина.
Це, по-перше. По-друге, ніколи про це розмова в такому ключі не йшла.
Він просто хоче показати, що він тут незадіяний.
Тобто тут він виконав свою частину контракту,
і він знову ж таки вигородив Володимира Путіна і себе.
А далі хоче, щоб йому дали спокій.
Британський експерт Майк Мартін вважає,
що для ПВК "Вагнер" велику роль відігравала особистість самого Євгена Пригожина,
тому головне питання зараз - чи зможе організація зберегти свою цілісність.
Я думаю, що якби все склалося так, як хочеться Путіну,
то ПВК "Вагнер" було б розділено.
Деякі її частини дістануться армії, деякі, можливо, будуть в Африці.
Таким чином, у Путіна буде кілька об'єднань, з якими він матиме справу.
При цьому, хоч ПВК "Вагнер" тепер зареєстрована у Білорусі,
керувати нею будуть із Москви, вважають експерти.
Лукашенко сам заявив, що за все платить Москва,
тобто за все платить хтось ще, за все, за останній аркуш паперу,
за чайник для намету. Все це оплачується іншою стороною.
Тому я думаю, що, звісно, Лукашенко у цій ситуації,
у всій цій ситуації із самого початку був весільним генералом.
Присутність "вагнерівців" на території Білорусі позначається на відносинах із сусідніми країнами.
Польща і Литва не виключають повного закриття кордонів.
Але, за словами Григорія Нижнікова, якогось особливо сенсу у присутності ПВК на території Білорусі немає.
Для чого її використати?
Для залякування Польщі?
Цим може займатись і білоруська армія, білоруські прикордонники.
Відповідно, швидше за все, ми можемо говорити про те, що до кінця року їх просто відправлять туди,
де вони потрібніші, до Африки, припустимо, до України.
Ми не знаємо. Найімовірніше, і туди, і туди.